sabre laser zumba ou encore tombola les
dix-huit mille étudiants de l'université
de versailles saint quentin avait
l'occasion de se divertir pour la
rentrée des associations la possibilité
pour eux également de découvrir sous le
soleil les événements et animations
prévues pour l'année universitaire
aujourd'hui nous avons 32 associations
qui ont leur agrément à l'université ça
va des associations de théâtre d ation
de musique des associations de la
solidarité de l'environnement sur la
nature voilà il ya vraiment de tout tout
est très diversifiée et ils sont très
actives
installé à proximité de la nouvelle
maison de l'étudiant les responsables
des associations répondent aux questions
propose des activités et tente d'attirer
les plus jeunes parfois intimidés
il faut quand même avec les étudiants
trouver une petite accroche pour leur
donner envie de deux dossiers intéressés
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a plusieurs
petits outils d'animation qui nous
permette de voilà de faire la croche qui
viennent nous voir par curiosité au
début et puis ensuite
ensuite ils vont finalement s'intéresser
et poser des questions mais c'est vrai
que de même c'est quelque chose dont ils
n'ont pas forcément l'habitude et ils
vont pas voilà savoir exactement ce
qu'ils peuvent y trouver la rentrée des
associations de l'ue vs cus poursuit le
mardi 27 septembre avec un rendez vous
cette fois ci sur le campus de
versailles